lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
explicar paso a paso la función de
ordenamiento por inserción que
escribimos en el vídeo anterior pero
antes de hacerlo quiero enfocarme en una
parte me di cuenta que use algo que
probablemente no reconozcan o que no
hayan usado antes use la palabra clave
break y probablemente ya sepan para que
sus esa palabra pero ahora quiero
explicarlo explícitamente lo que break
hace es salir del ciclo más pequeño que
se está ejecutando en este caso estamos
tomando un elemento y comparándolo con
lo que está a la izquierda lo que está
en la variable valor lo estamos
comparando con lo que está a la
izquierda y tan pronto como encontramos
algo que sea menor que valor ahí
terminamos ya no es necesario seguir con
las comparaciones a la izquierda y en
esa situación lo que quiero es romper el
ciclo salir del ciclo while y continuar
con la siguiente iteración del ciclo for
eso es lo que break hace en este caso
bueno ahora vayamos paso a paso a través
de este programa con un eje
lo simple empecemos por definir una
lista la lista que es igual a 2
32 creo que es una buena lista para
trabajar y asumimos que llamamos a la
función de ordenamiento por inserción
ordenamiento por inserción
ah
pensemos en lo que va a pasar aquí y voy
a poner todas las variables aquí abajo
así que tenemos la lista en su forma
original 2132 esta es la lista en el
momento de iniciar y luego entramos a la
función for índice en range y vamos a
revisar lo que está aquí que es ley de
lista leen de lista es lo mismo que
decir leen de 2132
y lo que hace esta función es obtener el
número de elementos de la lista leen es
la forma corta del ente longitud de la
lista y la longitud de esto que tenemos
aquí es 1234 es igual a 4 esto que está
aquí es igual a 4 y luego llamamos range
de 1,1 situ de la lista que es 4 y esto
nos va a regresar una lista empezando en
1 hasta 4 sin incluir 4
23 y estos son los índices que vamos a
usar el primer índice es este de aquí el
segundo es este y el tercero es este de
aquí recuerden este es el índice cero
así que el índice que vamos a usar se va
a ir incrementando entre estos primero
vamos a trabajar con el 1 luego con el 3
y luego con el 2 y voy a poner aquí la
variable índice es una variable que
tiene su alcance dentro del ciclo por
aquí escribo índice
y va a empezar con el valor que hay en
el primer elemento de la lista que nos
generó la función range 1 mal en de
lista entonces índice empieza con el
valor 1 y ahora tenemos esta variable
valor que es igual a lista en el
elemento índice aquí vamos a definir
nuestra variable valor y que hay en
lista índice lista de 1 cuál es el
primer elemento de la lista este es el
elemento 0 y este es el primer elemento
estamos revisando esta lista que tenemos
aquí este 1 es el primer elemento y
luego definimos la variable y que es
igual a índice menos 1 ponemos y por acá
con un color diferente y vemos que es
igual a índice menos 1 índice es 1 así
que índice menos 1 es cero este va a ser
el índice de lo que está a la izquierda
de valor este índice es igual a cero
este índice es 1 y este es 0
y luego decimos mientras si sea mayor o
igual a cero todo lo que está aquí y lo
primero que hacemos aquí es comparar
valor con el objeto que está en el
elemento y de la lista dejen escribir
esto aquí lista de iu y esto es igual al
elemento cero de la lista es igual a 2
es este 2
así que comparamos valor que es 1
comparamos uno y decimos si uno es menor
que el elemento y de la lista si uno es
menor que dos hazlo que sigue y
definitivamente uno es menor que dos
esencialmente lo que estamos haciendo es
tomar este uno y compararlo con lo que
está a la izquierda y como es menor lo
que tenemos que hacer es cambiar este 2
a la derecha y cambiar el uno a la
izquierda y luego regresamos aquí
decimos lista de iu + 1 que es y más 1 y
más uno es 1 así que este espacio que
tenemos aquí en el programa en este
momento es este de la lista este es el
primer espacio y lo vamos a reemplazar
que está en el elemento y de la lista
con lo que está en el elemento 0 de la
lista entonces lo reemplazamos con este
2 déjenme aclarar un poco este es 2 y
este es el espacio donde estaba el 1 así
que vamos a reemplazar 1 con el 2 y
luego en el lugar donde estaba el 2
vamos a reemplazarlo con valor recuerden
la variable valor es igual a 1 así que
lo reemplazamos con 1 entonces nuestra
lista ahora se ve así 1 2 3 2 y todo
esto parece familiar no si recuerdan la
primera vez que describí el algoritmo de
ordenamiento por inserción bueno ya
ejecutamos esto y ahora tenemos que
disminuir el valor de y el valor de y es
0 y le restamos 1 así que el nuevo valor
de iu es 1 negativo y es igual a 1
negativo y regresamos al ciclo while y
decimos mientras si es mayor o igual a 0
y vemos que ahora y es igual a 1
negativo así que esta condición no se
cumple y salimos del ciclo while ya no
vamos a ejecutar nada de esto y vamos a
la siguiente iteración del ciclo force y
lo que es importante entender es que ya
comparamos todo lo que estaba a la
izquierda del valor que empezamos a
comparar y que ese valor encontró su
lugar y ahora vamos de nuevo al ciclo
ford ahora índice va a ser igual al
siguiente elemento índice en lugar de
valer 1 va a ser igual al siguiente
elemento de la lista que se generó con
la expresión que tenemos aquí así que
índice ahora es 2 y lo cambiamos aquí
donde estamos registrando el valor de
nuestras variables
y ahora la variable valor va a ser igual
a lo que hay en la lista en el índice 2
y es este que tenemos aquí fíjense bien
estamos un espacio a la derecha de lo
que trabajamos en la pasada anterior así
que valor ahora va a ser igual a 3 y
ahora va a ser índice menos 1 índice es
22 menos 11 y lo ponemos aquí en el
valor de iu y decimos mientras sí sea
mayor o igual a 0 bueno claramente y es
mayor que 0 y es igual a 1 y hacemos la
comparación si valor es menor que lista
en i y vemos qué valores 3 y lista en y
es 2 vemos que ahí es igual a 1 así que
el elemento 1 de la lista es igual a 2 y
lo tenemos aquí si 3 es menor que 2
ejecuta lo que sigue pero esta condición
no se cumple y nos vamos a la cláusula
el que nos dice break sal del ciclo
salte de este ciclo while y esto tiene
sentido porque si comparamos el 3 con lo
que está inmediatamente antes
y no es menor entonces sabemos que el 3
está en el lugar correcto 3 no es menor
que 2 y no tengo que hacer cambios de
posición no tengo que cambiar el 3 a la
izquierda y el 2 a la derecha y luego
comparar con el siguiente elemento
porque sé que todo lo que está a la
izquierda ya está ordenado terminamos lo
dejamos como está así que salimos del
ciclo con break y vamos a la siguiente
iteración del ciclo for entonces ahora
índice va a ser igual al siguiente
elemento de esta lista generada con esta
expresión y va a ser igual a 3 índice
ahora va a ser igual a 3 valor ahora va
a ser igual a 0 1 2 3 ahora va a ser
igual a esto que tenemos aquí va a ser
igual a 2 y lo pongo aquí y la variable
y va a ser igual a índice menos uno
índice straits menos uno es igual a dos
y el objeto que tenemos en el segundo
elemento de la lista es
0 1 2 es igual a 3
y luego la primera cosa que hacemos es
decir mientras si es mayor o igual a 0 y
claro que iu es mayor o igual a 0
claramente lo vemos es 2 en este momento
entonces decimos si valor es menor que
lista de mi lista de mi estrés
así que 2 es menor que 3 y tenemos que
ejecutar los cambios que están aquí y lo
que hacemos es en el espacio de lista en
y + 1 y es 2 más 1 estrés en el espacio
del elemento 3 de la lista que es este
que está aquí tenemos que poner lo que
hay en lista y que es este 3 que tenemos
acá así que lo ponemos aquí y luego lo
que está en lista y lo tenemos que
reemplazar con lo que hay en la variable
valor así que esta cosa va a ser 2 de
nuevo y luego disminuimos el valor de iu
y ahora ahí es igual a 1 y vamos al
ciclo while una vez más
y es claramente mayor o igual a 0 y es
igual a 1 valor sigue siendo 2 recuerden
que en estas instrucciones comparamos
valor con todo lo que está a la
izquierda y aquí comparamos si 2 es
menor de lo que está en lista ahí y
vemos que lo que hay en lista ahí es
igual a valor no es menor así que ya no
tenemos que hacer nada
esto ya está ordenado el 2 está en el
lugar correcto si es igual no lo tenemos
que cambiar esto significa que lo que
hay a la izquierda es igual o menor así
que ya todo está ordenado entonces hemos
terminado si 2 no es menor que 2 nos
vamos a la cláusula else y salimos del
ciclo while en el ciclo for decimos okey
déjenme ver si hay algún elemento más en
esta lista para igualarlo a la variable
índice y vemos que ya no hay porque ya
los usamos todos entonces salimos del
ciclo for
terminamos y la lista ya debe estar
ordenada y vemos cómo queda la lista la
lista final se ve así